marcel patricia saint-aulaye bonjour
bonjour merci d'être avec nous est
coprésidente avec jonathan tabarre du
comité de soutien nicolas sarkozy nous
parlons forcément de cette campagne pour
la primaire de la droite et du centre
les choses se mettent en place d'autres
équipes est en ordre de marche depuis ce
week-end pour mettre en avant celui qui
selon vous porterez le mieux les
couleurs des républicains absolument
nous avons mis en place ce samedi le
comité de soutien à nicolas sarkozy qui
est notre candidat pour effectivement
rassembler les sarkozystes et peut voir
sur le département de la martinique
ce que nous avons a demandé est ce que
nous avons a précisé lu candidats sont
encore en lice en attend la liste finale
qui sera publié par la haute autorité ce
sera le 21 septembre dans dix jours
il faudra convaincre que nicolas sarkozy
sera l'homme de la situation
en dépit des soucis judiciaires du
moment savez monsieur viol tant que nous
sommes des grilles sarkozy ce sont des
gens de challenge et nous avons décidé
de soutenir ce candidat parce que nous y
croyons c'est un homme responsable c'est
un homme qui est à l' écoute et c'est un
homme qui saura donner en tout cas à la
martinique nous et nous ne nous en
sommes convaincus ce que nous attendons
et vous allez vous appuyez sur croient
justement pour convaincre les
martiniquais que c'est l'homme de la
situation sur son action présidentielle
lorsqu'il était aux commandes
alors il a un bilan qui est positif donc
sur son action perdait présidentielle et
nous allons aussi nous attacher avec les
directives qui nous seront données à
présenter des orientations qu'il nous
propose puisque nicolas sarkozy est un
homme qui questionne qui consultent et
qui écoute notamment via le mot plaisir
rien au plaisir est actuellement par on
y reviendra dans quelques dans quelques
instants
il ya mon plaisir qui semble être en
retrait par rapport à ceux ce comité de
soutien c'est une impression bien lui
qui s'était proclamé comme étant le plus
sarkozyste des sarkozystes à un moment
non je suivais mon plaisir est avec nous
d'ailleurs il était présent lors de la
création du comité
nous avons fait la première cellule il
était présent aujourd'hui il est à paris
et c'est le mec il va rencontrer nicolas
sarkozy
ils vont se dire croit à la bonne
question en tout cas nous allons nous
allons poser à nicolas sarkozy nos
demandes et nous allons regarder avec
son équipe
voldemort d'alors notre demande oui nous
avons nous avons la police ont muté avec
le nantais mickey nous avons la sécurité
nous avons la cherté de vie
nous avons la coopération régionale
surtout le développement économique et
beaucoup sur le développement économique
alors que peut que peuvent demander les
martiniquais qui soutiennent sarkozy a
éventuellement celui qui pourrait être
un chef de l'état de nouveau alors nous
allons leur poser la question justement
nous pouvons pas aujourd'hui répondre à
des questions que nous n'avons pas
encore posée aux martiniquais ou que des
martiniquais ne nous ont pas encore
expliqué de commencer à ce poste alors
nous avons mis à la disposition de tous
les électeurs puisque vous savez que les
primaires sur les primaires sont un sont
sont des élections qui sont ouverts à
tous les électeurs martiniquais et
martiniquais donc pour ce faire nous
avons mis une page facebook
nous avons un compte twitter et nous
avons un
une adresse d une adresse email nous
avons une cellule de communication qui
est très active et nous comptons nous
mettre à la disposition de toutes les
martiniquaises et de tous les
martiniquais pour pouvoir entendre
rapporté et effectuer une tâche ardue
lorsqu'on regarde bien là le paysage
politique partie dicaire plutôt à gauche
plutôt autonomistes plutôt à des patrons
6 tu as pas rentrer dans ce débat au
dessus pourquoi pas non aujourd'hui la
martinique a besoin même la martinique a
besoin de se faire entendre
donc il s'agit de faire entendre votre
voix auprès des martiniquais qui
montrent qu'ils votent majoritairement
pour le ppm pour le grand ensemble et
pumba en pays la chance ou le rdm
prendre à gauche ne savait dans le
comité nous avons de tout aujourd'hui
nous avons des gens qui sont à gauche
des gens qui sont centres des gens qui
sont à droite
nous avons de tout ça les gens à gauche
dans le cockpit de sa ronde des
électeurs martiniquais d'accord bon
alors le message le message sera que
nicolas sarkozy est l'homme de la
situation qui va par exemple la mise en
oeuvre ce fameux comité interministériel
pour l'outre-mer issue de la crise de
2009 est-ce que vous avez l'impression
depuis 2009 depuis sonneuse sociaux que
les choses ont évolué et qu'il peut
revendiquer une action positive
vis-à-vis de nous alors je nous pensons
nous pensons très sérieusement qu'il
peut revendiquer vis-à-vis d'un autre
d'ailleurs à cet effet rappelons que il
a su écouter nos élus et qu'aujourd'hui
nous sommes avec la c2 la collectivité
territoriale de martinique
c'est quand même quelque chose c'est un
grand pas pour la martinique c'est une
c'est une écoute qui a été sans faille
d'évolution institutionnelle c'est
toujours avec des hommes de droite c'est
ça non oui oui nous prenons alors on l'a
dit yan monplaisir est à paris est ce
que ce sera l'occasion pour pour lui de
dire après par exemple qu'il ne faudrait
pas faire les choses à moitié lorsqu'on
parle du développement économique de la
martinique à ne pas prendre de
demi-mesure faire les choses franchement
nous pensons aujourd'hui que le les
martiniquaises et des martiniquais
doivent avoir la vérité
nous pensons aujourd'hui que les
martiniquaises et les martiniquais
doivent comprendre que sans autorité
nous ne pourrons pas avancer nous
pensons aujourd'hui que les
martiniquaises et les martiniquaises
doit comprendre que nous sommes dans une
compétitivité mondiale et que
aujourd'hui nous devons faire tous
ensemble
l'autorité n'est pas suffisante selon
vous aujourd'hui l'autorité
l'autorité est à accroître les martinis
créations surtout focalisée par ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui en martinique le
lycée schoelcher qui est faite aux
débats le tcsp qui bâtit dans est ce
qu'ils ont envie de regarder vraiment ce
qui se passe de l'autre côté a surtout
qu'ils ont l'impression d'être un petit
peu les des laissés pour compte
laissé pour écouter avant d'aller
regarder de l'autre côté nous sommes
déjà de l'autre côté naturellement il
législativement avant d'aller regarder
de l'autre côté regarde on chez nous
faisons chez nous et c'est ce que
nicolas sarkozy dit nicolas sarkozy dit
prenez vos responsabilités
donc nous sommes derrière ce candidat
parce que nous devons prendre nos
responsabilités la plupart des
dirigeants de ou de la fédération de
martinique et de la section martinique
des républicains ont affiché leur
préférence pour alain juppé comment ça
se passe et la campagne en interne
non je pense pas qu'on puisse parler
comme ça vous savez nous avons une
chance aujourd'hui c'est au niveau de la
fédération et du parti d'avoir nounou
candidat républicain au niveau de la
primaire de
de la droite et du centre c'est une
chance extraordinaire parce que c'est
bien ce sont bien les primaires de la
droite et du centre
c'est le parti républicain qui
représentait donc nous sommes tous une
grande famille et non la diversité des
candidats le choix des candidats au
contraire de l'ouverture à l'ensemble
des martiniquaises et des martiniquais
pour pouvoir se positionner
est ce que vous avez entendu les propos
de françois fillon a servi à sablé sur
sarthe 1 à la fin du mois d'août
non seulement réalisé entendu mais je
lise il lui je ne reviendrai pas dessus
parce que je suis quand même
non j'ai lu les candidats il faut quand
même dire quelque chose non je veux
parler de mon candidat je veux pas
parler des autres candidats le principe
est de rester chacun à sa place et nous
nous avons nous avons mis cette
stratégie en place que nous voulons
respecter nicolas sarkozy à l'époque
dans les années 2000 il avait quand même
quelques petites préférences pour les
bienfaits positif de la colonisation
française vous rappeler nicolas sarkozy
a largement des petites phrases 2 a
largement les petites phrases vous les
retenaient mais retenons surtout ce
qu'il a fait nous pourrions parler d'eux
dans la retraite nous pourrions parler
de la défiscalisation nous pond il a
fait beaucoup de choses aujourd'hui
il y à cette primaire pour la droite et
le centre
il y à aussi en arrière fond les
législatifs qui se prépare est ce que
vous y pensez également est ce que c'est
quelque chose qui risque de de brouille
le message il ne faut pas que ça
brouille le message et chaque chose en
son temps aujourd'hui nous sommes sur
les primaires donc nous allons nous
focaliser sur les primaires et en temps
voulu nous reviendrons vers vous et
présenteront les programmes les
stratégies les les organisations des
législatives mais oui nous y pensons
comment ça se passait avec avec les
militants chacun sur le terrain comment
ça se passe et vous irez 2
comités un comité de commune en commune
de circonscription par circonscription
vous irez chez l'habitant
ce sera des débats face à face avec par
exemple ceux qui soutiennent alain juppé
alors concernant l'organisation du
comité de nicolas sarkozy nous ne
pouvions pas nous prononcer tant que le
candidat ne s'était pas ne s'était pas
déclarée
mais nous travaillons depuis des mois à
la venue éventuelle de notre candidat
puisque nous y pensions et nous y
croyons
sur l'organisation oui nous avons
aujourd'hui alors je vais parler de
sections géographiques pour ne pas avoir
de confusion donc nous avons à
aujourd'hui à l'heure où je vous parle
22 sarkozyste qui se sont prononcés
proposé pour animer des sections
géographiques et je pense qu'il y en a
eu encore deux autres
après la conférence de presse donc nous
sommes sur le terrain et nous voulons
être prêts de la population
martiniquaise est ce qu'il y aura le
débat le débat que tout le monde attend
toujours pour tous les indécis
ce qu'ils ne savent pas trop où pencher
monsieur vialleton s'il ne s'agissait
que de moi je serai satisfait qu'il y
ait ce débat là je ne parle pas pour les
autres je parle de moi je parle toujours
de fin de jeu par le nom puisque je
n'oublie pas mon co présidents nous nous
ne sommes pas
hostile à la georgie là la chose la
première sera de toute façon au coeur de
cette primaire à de la droite et du
centre je pense que nous aurons
l'occasion d'entendre toutes façons
c'est qu'ils supportent à la jupe en
tout la nouveau amercia marcel patricia
cet honnête d'avoir c'était le jeu de
venir comme ça au pied levé parce que
c'était marie-france tools que nous
avions annoncé qu'ils avaient empêché
mans de dernière minute merci d'avoir
été ce matin avec nos dents 5 à 10 on
vous souhaite une très bonne journée
merci merci